but did you know in the sequel to  Forrest Gump there was a scene where you  saw the towers go down no shut the [ __ ]  up yeah yeah I was friends with a couple  hijackers and they didn't tell me what  they was gonna do yeah their first Gump  is a dog [ __ ] movie oh we all got swept  away in the moment let's get in not for  one man one man was not swept away  do you think there was a part where he  was there was this like an Al Qaeda  member and he's like but the United  States is so strong he's like I would  just take out a couple of their  buildings  dude you know the world World Trade  Center is also a financial Capital  shark yeah dark Forrest Gump so if you  don't lock your little beautiful  daughter you should do something about  it Mr Ramsay